this app is so weird hinge is so weird I
hate hate hate the voice when the guys
do the voice not I knew you're going to
say that why they're shootings in the
foot with that why are they doing it by
way how about this no I'll give you an
example I'm so I'm on a roll right now
heated I get a message from a guy we're
talking casually and then he just sends
me
[Music]
this
what am I supposed to do with that was
that the T me he devil what did you
match with I was literally thinking am I
supposed to reverse it and that's what
he's really trying to say is he speaking
in tongue right now like what is this
Morris code bull like why they're so
Strange's like yes what the